un couloir devenu familier victor o
l'empreinte depuis plusieurs mois pour
rejoindre son labo musicale la suite 101
stop on arrête tout laissez moi d'abord
vous raconter l'histoire de cette suite
désormais célèbre une chambre d'hôtel
d'une vingtaine de mètres carrés à
l'alluré vintage dépouillé et en sus une
déco revisité avec l'installation d'une
fresque imaginé par victor o et réalisé
par gribouillis graphiste et
martiniquaise petit à petit que ça s'est
imposé que ça allait s'appeler fille de
son impasse qu'effectivement album
n'aurait pas été pareil cela a été fait
ici que nous sommes d'hôtel aussi c'est
un bon point de départ pour parler du
monde tout en voyage comme ça un peu
partout on y entendra assez neutre mais
dans des pays différents et donc voilà
c'est un endroit c'est notre mai de
cette chambre d'hôtel voilà on est on
est parti au sénégal on a été en france
si les murs de la suite 101 pouvaient
parler ils chanteraient les textes et
les mélodies créé ici au moins cinq
morceaux de l'album mis en pl été
enregistrés dans le plus grand secret et
surtout dans la sérénité requise lors de
ce type d'exercice où l'esprit mise à
rude épreuve
allez il est temps maintenant victoire
au viennent nous livrer son inspiration
m
[Musique]
oui
on s'est concentré sur en fait tout
départ neuf chansons et on ira en a
rajouté une chanson qui sait déjà qui
s'appelle under construction
on a fait une version acoustique avec un
super guitariste appelle la rafle à
vital est donc surtout ce sont des
chansons qui sont des chansons d'une
année particulière pour moi qui étais
allé j'ai perdu mon père est donc ça
s'est construit chose qui existait déjà
avant et donc ça a construit l'album de
manière particulière aujourd'hui l'album
suite 101 sur le marché lanmou éternelle
c'est déjà un tube et le labo musicale
sert désormais de studio photo les
modèles les plus inattendus défilent et
prennent la pose de victor o comme
christelle notre reporter d'image et
pour ceux qui se demandent ce qu'il se
passait d'autres dans la suite 101